we got this story from ABC7 grand jury
could get Subway Chokehold death of
Jordan Neely case next week so they're
actually a law enforcement Source
removed investigation tells ABC News the
probe into the subway Chokehold death is
continuing the case is likely to go to a
grand jury next week I will say this too
I believe the man's name is Daniel penny
you are going to go to prison for a very
very long time I don't know I hope not
eyewitnesses man there's a lot of
eyewitnesses that I don't think that
matters that's all that matters the
entire conversations that the
conversation that we've been having uh
is that like Kyle Rittenhouse for
instance would have would be in prison
for the rest of the life the rest of his
life if it was true that the people he
shot in self-defense were black
what we're likely going to see like with
the Ahmed Aubry case uh this man I think
his name is Daniel penny is likely going
to be politically convicted that's it I
mean you've got AOC calling for him to
be she's calling him a murderer she's
not even saying it's Reckless homicide
or negligence she's saying outright
that's for a jury to decide yeah exactly
but you but you've got someone with 13
million followers
inciting violence in uh this is what
she's doing AOC I mean she's inciting
violence in New York City by calling
this guy a murderer and obfuscating the
facts she wants people in New York she
is like the Joker she is she is she well
more like Lex Luthor right Lex Luthor
became president that's right he did
here's an interesting thing we
discovered actually while filming
infringed is a lot of people especially
on the Progressive side of things will
look at these lower level crimes like
the mental illness assaults on uh the
subway they'll be like oh it's just like
a small thing this and that or in
Baltimore when we were filming oh they
have possession of an illegal weapon
well they didn't kill anyone they didn't
Rob anything so we're just not gonna the
progressive DA's would just be like
whatever we're not even gonna deal with
these cases they're like misdemeanors
but what occurs is when they don't deal
with those lower level cases they almost
always end up becoming more high-level
criminals it leads to murder it leads to
um you know horrible assaults horrible
robberies violence because you have to
deal with it if people start to like
test the water a bit oh I can get away
with that test the water a bit more you
can't have people getting away with
these low-level misdemeanors constantly
you can't have things like illegal
weapons carrying in Baltimore be just
like not a West whatsoever well this is
why giuliani's Broken Window policing
was effective you have to stop the
smaller crimes because it's not only the
case as you acknowledge that people who
commit these lower level crimes are in
some sense testing the water and seeing
what they can get away with even just
subconsciously but it's also the case
that if you know people are getting the
book thrown at them for misdemeanors
you're going to think twice about a
felony you're gonna think twice about
committing a felony
for sure I have mixed feelings about
about just just going hard to people for
Mr like drug possession marijuana well
that's just stupid laws like I don't
think like I I personally I'm okay with
Canada having marijuana legalized I
think the U.S should follow suit I just
think that should legalize yeah I think
it's wasted so it's wasting time it's
wasting money it's there's so much real
crime going on in this country that
could be using up the yeah but real
quick what we are seeing is that they're
legalizing drug use they're legalizing
the right to set up homeless camps in
public spaces and then they're
criminalizing self-defense so it's the
inverse and also
when it comes to a federal War on Drugs
I oppose it I don't think there's
anything wrong with a particular State
saying we want to ban this drug or that
drug however I I don't think it's wise
as a nation to have this bizarre
two-faced halfway point where we say
this drug is illegal or X Y and Z is
illegal but it's not that serious a
crime you're not really going to get
into that much trouble if something is a
crime it should really be a crime and
that does mean we need to think twice
about what laws we have what we're
willing to ban or make illegal but once
something's not legal you really should
get in serious trouble for breaking the
law I agree with that it makes a mockery
of the judicial system or the entire CIS
legal system if you can't enforce or
don't enforce a law on the book so like
schedule one marijuana's schedule one
narcotic in the United States federally
but it's like no we're not going to
pursue it they don't they won't pursue
it it's legal in the state let me show
you this from Vivek ramaswamy in 2015
Jordan nearly Neely kidnapped a
seven-year-old girl in 2019 he punched a
64 year old man in the face in 2021 he
slugged a 67 year old woman in the face
as she exited the subway breaking her
nose and fracturing her orbital bone he
was arrested 44 times but never faced
real Justice for terrorizing New Yorkers
shares responsibility for his death for
creating an anti-law enforcement culture
you read that kidnapped a seven-year-old
kid thing and I'm just like nah I'm
sorry I'm trying well he did the
movement he Moonwalks though
because that makes me mad as hell and
and uh uh uh I can't play this video
no this is a video of him screaming
homophobic slurs at Joey Boots oh well
that's the real problem forget about the
kidnapping no I will I will say this
this is a video from DC Drano where he
says the video of Jordan Neely uh going
viral showing him violently assaulting a
man using homophobic slurs the f word
um I've I've not confirmed this so I
don't know that it's true but it does
look like it's him like in the video
there's a video of a guy looks just like
Nelly he's doing Michael Jackson stuff
it looks like all the other videos so I
believe it's probably correct that it is
him but I want to make sure I have that
caveat because you know take it with you
deep faces now but this is
and I know Joey Boots and there's never
a reason to have gone up you know rest
in peace Joey there was never a reason
to scream at him and threaten him
because this is not what Joey did Joey
had a video of like walking up to Tucker
Carlson he's like he's filming he walks
around New York filming oh yeah I
remember the video and Tucker is like
I'm fishing and he's like oh cool and
he's like Tucker Carlson fishing in New
York and Tucker's just like yeah and
that and then that's it Joey would do
these videos and he would go up to news
cameras and say Baba Booey Baba Booey so
when you see a video of this Neely guy
he was a violent angry dude he was mean
he attacked people he kidnapped people
how is it that this the villain the
perpetrator is what AOC and the left you
know how because this is the behavior
that they deem acceptable what this is
the behavior they deem acceptable like
mentally ill
so if a person behaves violently
in an insane way in a reckless way or
just in a flat out immoral way their
entire philosophy and the entire
philosophy of the left is the only
reason that person behaved that way is
because of certain systemic structures
that push them in that direction and so
they're not the criminal you are for not
supporting left-wing policy now that I I
understand because that is an argument
I've seen being made by people for in
that camp if there's that's what's
happening
um is that Society failed this guy flat
out he should have been either put an
institution of some sort or put in jail
after his 44th Crime After maybe it's
stealing the seven-year-old it seemed
like he wanted to go back to jail right
you know
um he probably wants to get fed three
times a day and if you're in jail that's
what you get right so uh because I saw
something that um I saw a tweet you know
I don't know who said it but um you know
he was saying something like uh you know
I'll go back to jail or I want to go
back to jail it's like well if there was
an asylum for somebody like this you
know he'd be taken care of he'd be off
the streets I mean meanwhile he's
homeless he's probably hungry you'd
probably save money too in police
resources constantly dealing with these
issues like sending them to an asylum
this Vancouver this is exactly why we
got the problems there they shut I think
it's Riverside there was a massive
mental Asylum and they basically let
everyone loose shut it down I know
during the Reagan Era a ton of mental
asylums were shut down as well and it's
just like boom on the streets you think
the resources that were going into those
asylums aren't going to into police
investigations solving these issues now
yeah
no oh sorry no yeah go ahead well no and
this is something I touched on the show
yesterday that happened during the
Reagan Era this was also a product of
the fukuyan de-institutionalization
movement this idea on the left that
mental illness is for the most part a
social construct and we need to be more
understanding and it's true that in many
mental health facilities people were
mistreated and there was a serious
conversation that needed to be had there
however in the 1950s there were 500 000
people committed to mental institutions
across the U.S and then by the mid 80s
that falls to 100 000. is that after
Reagan letting people out or before I I
think I'm not sure at which point the
vast majority of the decrease in those
numbers occurred but I do know that
between the 1950s and the 1980s you just
have a massive
um I would say decrease in the number of
people in mental health facilities
across the country and part of that as a
result of the reclassification of what
it requires to get somebody committed so
it used to be you have to be proven to
be unable to take care of yourself and
then they change that uh standard to you
have to have been proven to be a threat
to yourself all for others now often
when someone proves that they're a
threat to themselves or others it's too
late someone's already been hurt so I
don't know if the standard should be
they can't take care of themselves as it
used to be but I think the standard we
have now clearly isn't working it looks
like it was 81 the when Reagan's ended
the mental health systems Act of 1980.
he like right when he got it off is that
true right is there something in
California I think as well he signed a
bill I think the lantris Peterson yeah
that's 1967 that he did that yeah
did you know this sorry random
interesting fact right there's so many
Reagan facts I learned while doing the
infringe stuff he was one of the first
people to pass one of the mass gun
control they'll act as Governor yeah
Reagan was not was certainly far from
perfect like everyone Praises him
because of the way he stood up to
Communism and I think that that was
great I think that was great I will not
take that from him however he was
certainly not the best president
Americans he had a lot of great
one-liners though I think that's right
he like doubled the amount of federal
employees though while standing against
communism
no it was like pencil push paper pushers
whatever there's a lot of those in the
military though that he was like really
didn't like George we're senior sorry
does that need a corkscrew yeah I was
going to ask if you could open this
there's a corkscrew running out of L Tim
don't open it for her she's gonna put I
saw that she opened it but then she
didn't do it she's gonna put Diet Coke
in it and it's a 25 year old scotch
such an expensive booze and it just
breaks when I twist it slightly because
people like you who don't know what
they're doing are gonna ruin it and so
they intentionally design it it's like
child proofing but for people who put
Diet Coke in their alcohol
now what Reagan uh cuddle Ronald I heard
that Reagan hated George maybe I hate it
but really didn't like George Bush
Senior really at all they were I think
they ran against each other if I'm
predator
and then like what the Deep State went
to him and was like you're gonna have
imagination attempt and then after that
he made him his VP I mean I don't know
if that's true but I've heard that story
yeah so this Reagan guy I mean was he
one of those guys who's like going in
with all the righteousness and then as
soon as he gets in there like here's
your talking here's your Playbook by the
way and he's like uh I don't think so
then bang bang and then he's like okay
I'll play ball well this is what's crazy
is even when he wasn't because you know
I was getting in a debate with my dad
about this lovey dad
um and we were talking about Reagan and
gun control he's like oh you know he was
more Democrat early on he probably
changed his mind and I'm like yeah you
know he did a lot of good things in
government but actually even when he was
out of office he wrote into
um wrote to lawmakers supporting the
assault weapons ban that Biden passed
saying I support this put this through
and that was after yeah
he was out of office right and that's
what we have to remember firstly Reagan
said something it's quite a famous quote
and this is something that many people
who are considered Centrist or you know
2010 era liberals say today what Reagan
said was I am considered conservative
just for holding to the liberal
principles that I had 20 years ago
something along those lines Reagan was
not the far right conservative that the
left made him out to be because we
should understand that no fault divorce
well because look at it I mean everyone
thinks Reagan was this far a
conservative president okay well they
call Tim Poole far right today so of
course in the 80s when they were calling
yeah when they were calling Reagan far
right that didn't mean anything then
either wow I wanna I wanna thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time